something something something dark side
I'm really running out of ways to intro
the Star Wars episodes hey everybody so
let's talk about Star Wars again I kind
of thought I was done talking about this
after I did my second video because I
thought I had ranted out everything that
I had to say about the movie and because
after I did my second video like I I've
still got problems with the last Jedi
they haven't gone away
I however those problems aren't making
me angry anymore so I'm probably in a
space where I'm gonna I'm gonna be okay
to watch it again
see if it gets any better but I do have
to talk about the box office cuz second
weekend is in and the news is not great
so some context because box office
numbers are funny because you look at
them and usually they paint a pretty
clear picture but people love to just
twist them and try and make them mean
what they want them to mean and honestly
I didn't want this to be the box office
story because if it wasn't I wouldn't
have to be talking about this movie
again but basically the second weekend
drop off that this thing had from its
first weekend was just shy of 69% now if
you don't follow box office numbers a
lot anything anything over 60 is bad
general rule of thumb if you can keep
between 50 and 55 you're doing pretty
good now for comparison the force
awakens in its second weekend dropped
less than 40 percent and actually
maintained only dropping off that little
in its third weekend so that movie had
really good legs as far as these things
go because honestly anything under 50
your that's a maze
retention but just under 69% and that is
that's it's not quite there but that is
closer to Batman V Superman second
weekend drop-off so no matter what you
try and tell me about what's going on
you know in international box office in
this or that like that is the kind of
drop-off especially compared to what the
retention was on the last film that they
that was in this primary series I
guarantee you that there are
conversations going on at Lucasfilm if
not at Disney as well right now because
that's just that's a big hit versus what
the the previous numbered saga film did
so the question now becomes what happens
next and we're in a little bit of an odd
situation because we already know that
Rian Johnson isn't directing and the
next one and in fact they were already
bringing back the guy who did the force
awakens so it's funny because it's
almost like they preemptively did the
kind of move that normally would be a
reflexive move following a bad reception
so like getting JJ Abrams back if that
was happening right now if that news was
coming out now we would all go oh
they're doing that because the the
financial windfall on force awakens was
much better people seemed less divided
over that so they're bringing back to
fix the franchise except that he was
brought in a while before and I'm sure
they'll become conspiracy theories about
Lucasfilm knowing it was gonna not fly
like I really don't think so I
everything and about the lead-up to this
I and hype is weird because when a
marketing arm were really heavily pushes
something sometimes it's because they
have the studio's faith in it and
sometimes it's because they think they
have a massive turd and they need to get
as many people's button the seats the
first weekend as possible for
word-of-mouth gets out but you know
between the really stellar reviews and
every
about the lead up I don't think they
thought they had a problem film on their
hands I really don't but again we're in
this weird situation where they already
did the movie that normally would have
been the reflex reaction so we are in a
really weird place right now and even
before this this box-office news came in
I think JJ Abrams was all was already in
in an unenviable position because I
think one of my big problems with the
last Jedi is that regardless of which
you like better whether it's the force
awakens or whether it's the last Jedi I
think it's hard to argue that it is not
painfully obvious that they were made by
different filmmakers who had different
interests different fundamental things
about this franchise that they wanted to
do or wanted to explore I think that's
really obvious and it makes for Owen it
makes for a fairly jarring shift from
one film to the next cuz it really does
feel like one director looking at what
was left for him by the previous one
going nope nope nope we're doing this
instead and that's not me necessarily
saying like I needed the film's to like
be this complete no it's the all the
logical steps from what came before like
I'm fine with theoretically going
somewhere else but it really did feel
like they were through eve was throwing
a lot of the old stuff away and I
suspect because I mean I know there's
the there's the petition to remove
episode a from canvas that's it oh my
god people come on grow up there's gonna
be a lot of people who didn't like the
force awakens who are gonna be going
okay so JJ Abrams is gonna have to fix
this and fix all the stuff and bring
back all the things that Brian Johnson
sort of threw out and this is gonna
sound weird coming from somebody who
didn't like the last Jedi but no that's
a really bad idea because JJ Abrams
needs it needs to do
the things that I think Ryan Johnson
didn't do which is consider not only the
film that he's making but its place in
the franchise and I know that can be a
restrictive line of thinking for a
filmmaker to have to go through but you
know and I said this in my second video
you've got the spin-off stuff to go wild
and do other stuff with Star Wars with
which Rian Johnson is now doing although
I have to wonder if there's any jeopardy
about that based off the reception's of
this I kind of hope not cuz for all my
issues with the last Jedi I Brian
Johnson a good filmmaker he did
interesting choices I just I just wished
that a lot of what he was exploring
hadn't been explored with the main
franchise and I've been done inside
budgets in the first place
so I kind of hope that doesn't get
torpedoed now because I think honestly
that's where they shouldn't just put him
in the first place but I I'm hoping that
JJ Abrams because Rian Johnson really
did seem to focus on his movie only with
almost a flagrant disregard for what was
built up to what could be done after or
what fan expectations were and again
that's not me saying it should have all
been dictated to him exactly what it
should or shouldn't have been but it
seems like you didn't take it into
consideration at all and when you're
doing the eighth film and a nine film
series to have such little regard for
not only the earlier films but the film
immediately preceding yours and to leave
things in such a state that it's like
we're how do you even make another story
after that it really does feel like he
had such tunnel vision on making his
movie and in my opinion to the detriment
of not the Star Wars brand but to the
numbered saga as a whole and I think JJ
Abrams would do more damage to try and
crowbar it back to where you're closer
to where maybe he would have picked it
up if he had done episode 8 instead of
Rian Johnson because what that's gonna
result in so it look if we set the first
six aside for a second and we just look
at this as a three film trilogy
if JJ Abrams's basically makes a film
that feels like a sequel to the force
awakens and does what Rian Johnson did
and by and large disregards who tosses
aside or diminishes a lot of what he did
in Episode eight then we don't have a
trilogy what we have is basically the
equivalent of cinematic ping-pong as two
directors just keep going back and forth
batting at this franchise and just not
creating anything cohesive at all I
don't want that I hadn't I got I got
enough tonal whiplash and thematic harsh
turns from Episode eight I don't need
those turns made again trying to
quote-unquote correct it and I'm sure
there are a lots of people who don't
like Episode a towards is going look I'm
just removing it from my head Canon so I
want him to disregard it but again I I
may not have liked the last Jedi
particularly but that doesn't mean I
want it in pretending like it's not
there this is not this is not a
situation like Justice League where the
only way to move forward is to actively
abandon what you were trying to build up
to this point I don't think that's
necessary
it is better for the franchise it is
better for the story as a whole to move
forward rather than to go back and try
and fix the last movie because then
episode 9 is not its own story it's not
a story in and of itself it's a
corrective and it's almost impossible to
be on a good energetic well-made
well-told
engaging story while also primarily
trying to correct something previously
again that was that was a big part of
Justice League's problem and again I I
was pleasantly surprised by Justice
League it's not a particularly good
movie though because so much of what's
going on and is bogged down in trying to
redirect this this entire franchise of
the DC EU and telling its own story is
secondary maybe even tertiary to that
and I don't want to see Star Wars fall
into that trap now that's that I don't
envy JJ Abrams is position cuz like I
said it really does feel like Rian
Johnson not only wanted to do his own
thing he kind of he kind of really
kicked JJ Abrams and stuff is like I'm
not just gonna do my own thing I'm gonna
get that stuff out of here I don't want
that anywhere near me so it's got a
imagine it is probably gonna be really
frustrating for him but I just I don't
need this
I don't now that we've sort of whipped
one way I didn't enjoy it I'm not gonna
enjoy it if you try and whip me back
again and it's not like I like necessary
I like being over here but like if
anything like maybe gently ease me back
don't try and yank me back into more of
what the force awakens was and I know
I'm using these terms and I know it's a
little it's a little bit weird because
it's hard to quantify because I'm
largely talking about just the how the
whole things have approached the the
general feel and vibe from film to film
these last couple cuz honestly it's just
weird I mean going from the force
awakens to the last Jedi that is a weird
weird shift and I don't want another
weird weird shift so and yeah and I
honestly think JJ Abrams could make a
movie that caps off this trilogy that
doesn't feel as a Don's because JJ
Abrams one of his really great skills
possibly even his primary skill is being
really good at assimilating and sort of
adopting the technique and the feel and
the vibe of other filmmakers I mean it's
it's what made him really ideal to make
on the force awakens in the first place
it's you know it's why he did things
like super 8 which felt so much like
Spielberg like he's just really good at
that I think that he can adopt enough of
what Rian Johnson did in terms of tone
and feel and look to create something
that feels like a smooth transition out
of that and not the jarring transition
from force awakens to the last Jedi that
we got before so again as much as I
don't really like the last Jedi very
much I'm not thrilled with this news
because I don't
the possible resulting chaos - just get
me a really wonky middling just trying
to correct continuity 9th film this is
something I didn't really talk about too
much of my videos before on episode 8
I'll try not to bog this one down in it
too much but something that I've come to
a better realization of since I've made
those earlier videos is that episode 8
feels like an ending like a total ending
and not just because that last shot
really feels like it's a shot that you
should go at the very end of a saw of
the saga as a whole but it's it's
because all the characters feel like
their journeys are kind of done so you
know in terms of the characters who had
decisions injuries to make kylo Ren
makes his choice Rey makes her choice
Finn comes to a better understanding of
himself makes his choice Poe grows a bit
as a character and it doesn't feel like
there's decisions left to be made at
this point so it's not like I needed a
cliffhanger at the end of the thing but
if you're gonna make the comparison to
the Empire Strikes Back which I know is
a popular thing for defenders of the
film to do because they like to point
out that reception was actually pretty
divided for Empire Strikes Back when it
first came out but one of the things I
would point to is at the end of that
movie even if you set aside the
cliffhanger of can they rescue Han there
were a lot of journeys that weren't
complete like you didn't know how the
knowledge that Luke just got about Darth
Vader being his father was going to
affect him and what choices he was going
to make as a result of that Lando just
came on board how much can we trust him
we don't know what choices that
character is going to make having now
learn this new information about Vader
it makes you reassess him like how much
do we understand the choices he already
has made and what choices will we now
see him make there were journeys
character journeys that weren't complete
yet I feel like character journeys are
kind of done that's not to say that
these characters have no things to do
left in their lives but like as their
personal journey coming to an
understanding of who they are and making
the core big decision of their life I
feel like they all made it like it's all
done at this point all there is all this
left to do is play out the strings that
leaves me really unmotivated to see a
ninth film but I just kind of just kind
of tacked that on because it was a I
know they thought I had I didn't want to
make another video stick sclusively
talking about the last Jedi even though
this this video was supposed to be more
about the my worries about the franchise
as a whole cuz honestly I didn't have a
ton I had some coming out of the last
Jedi I've got even more now with the box
office because when Studios start to
scramble and panic is when they do
really dumb stuff because Justice League
was made as a result of a scramble and a
panic arguably BVS was to that one's a
little bit more debatable but some other
they amazing spider-man 2 was the result
of a scramble and a panic cuz Sony was a
little bit underwhelmed with amazing
spider-man 1 it was so desperate to
launch a whole franchise of films that
they scrambled and got desperate and
made that mess Universal desperately
wanted a cinematic universe and in the
the scramble to try and create one we
got the mummy when Studios get panicky
and scrambled we get really bad movies
so I don't know what the plan for Star
Wars was prior to these box office
numbers but I just hope that it's not
getting thrown into chaos as a result of
these box office numbers if they want to
take a quick second look at it fine-tune
it okay but I just I really hope that
it's that there aren't right now board
rooms full of yelling executives
pointing fingers saying we need to
change everything because that's that's
just kind of results in a lot of really
bad movies and I 2017 was an odd year
for me at the movies because there were
a lot of movies that caught me off guard
in a good way but there were a lot of
disappointments and most of the
disappointments were in were from films
that I was really
looking forward to in franchises that I
had trusted up to that point and I don't
need Star Wars to start to enter into
the same realm that the DCE you landed
in after a while for me so that's that's
sort of where my brain has gone as a
result of the box office numbers that we
found out for Star Wars the last Jedi in
its second weekend what are your
thoughts on all this whatever they are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it all the stuff like
subscribe I'm on Twitter I got a podcast
links for all that stuff's down in the
description and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]